- [Instructor] We're told that a train
traveling through Japan has 90 passengers.
52 passengers get off in Tokyo.
In Kobe, another 29
passengers get off the train.
No new passengers get on the train.
And then they ask us how many passengers
are still on the train?
Pause this video and see if
you can work through that
before we work on this together.
All right, now let's do this together.
So first, what we can think about
is how many total passengers there are,
and then to figure out how many are left,
well, you have to start with your total,
take away 52 that get off in Tokyo,
then take away another
29 that get off in Kobe,
and then however many you have left,
that's how many are still on the train.
And we can imagine that
with a tape diagram.
So let's say that the length of this tape
or the length of this rectangle
represents the initial,
the starting 90 passengers.
So that's 90 passengers.
And then how many get off in Tokyo, 52,
and I'm doing this so
that we can visualize it,
so we can think about what it looks like.
So we'll take away 52, which
might be something like this.
So 52 off in Tokyo,
Tokyo,
and then we have another 29 passengers
that get off the train in Kobe.
So then another 29, maybe
that's something like this,
get off in Kobe, so 29 off in Kobe.
And so how many passengers are still left?
Well, if you start with 90,
52 get off in Tokyo, 29 get off in Kobe,
then this last part of
the length of the tape,
that would be how many are left.
So right over there,
this is the, how many,
how many, how many left,
would be the length of
this red part of the tape.
'Cause we've taken off the
52 and the 29 off of the 90.
So to figure that out, we
could first try to figure out
what is 90 minus 52?
If you haven't figured that out,
you could pause the video
and try to figure that out.
All right, well, one
way to think about it,
90 minus 52 is the same thing
as 90 minus 50 minus two.
So I could write it this
way, minus 50 minus two.
And you might recognize that 90 minus 50,
that's 9 tens minus 5 tens,
that's going to be 4 tens.
This is going to be 40.
So this is going to be 40 minus 2,
and then 2 less than 40,
well, that's going to be 38.
So this is going to be equal to 38.
So if you only had that one
stop after that first stop,
you have 38 passengers left on the train.
And so that 38 is this
amount right over here.
But then we know another
29 get off in Kobe.
So we need to start with that 38,
and 29 are going to get off, so minus 29.
And we can view this as,
maybe we could rewrite this,
this is equal to 30 plus 8, that's 38,
and we're going to subtract 20 and 9.
So subtract 20 and subtract 9.
This wouldn't be subtract
20 and then add 9.
That wouldn't be 29.
We're subtracting 2 tens and 9 ones.
So we're subtracting 20 and 9.
So first, we could view
this as 30 minus 20,
which is going to be 10.
And then we're going to
add 8 and then subtract 9,
subtract 9.
Now, what is 10 plus 8?
10 plus 8 we know is 18.
Now, if we subtract 9 from 18,
you might already know
that that's going to be 9.
Another way to think about it
is if you subtract 8 from 18,
you're going to be just left with 10,
and then you have one more to take away.
So you're going to be left with 9.
So we are going to have 9
passengers left on the train.
Start with 90, 52 get
off, there's 38 left.
Then another 29 get off.
Now we have 9 left.